– Woher stammt Inges Familie?
Was glaubt ihr?
Na? Wer möchte es versuchen?
– Ich glaube, dass sie
aus Deutschland kommt.
– Ja … und nein.
Der Ort, aus dem meine Familie kommt,
liegt heute in Polen.
Aber als meine Eltern dort lebten,
lag er noch in Deutschland.
– Wer kann mir sagen, wann das war?
– Das war bestimmt vorm Zweiten Weltkrieg.
– Ganz genau.
Und als Deutschland den Krieg
verloren hat,
mussten meine Eltern
unsere Heimat verlassen.
Da war ich noch nicht geboren.
– Gab es damals genauso viele
Flüchtlinge wie heute?
– Ha! Sogar mehr.
Und die Menschen kamen in ein Land,
in dem sehr viel kaputt war.
Immerhin konnten sie
die Sprache verstehen.
Denn sie haben auch zu Hause
Deutsch gesprochen.
Das war sicher ein großer Vorteil.
Da hat es deine Familie nicht so leicht.
– Wo ist Ihre Heimat?
Hier oder der Ort,
aus dem Ihre Familie stammt?
– Ja, das kleine Dorf, aus dem meine Familie
kommt, ist auch ein Teil von mir.
Ach, meine Mutter hat mir viele Geschichten
aus ihrer Jugend und Kindheit dort erzählt.
Ich bin mit meinen Eltern
noch ein paar Mal da gewesen.
Aber meine Heimat ist hier, in Deutschland.